يا هلا والله فيك واهلا بك واهلا بينادين
وصباح الخير امس ترى على فكره ما قدرت
اصبح عليكم كويس انه كلنا في قاعه
اختبارات وكنت مع طلاب محروم من اني اصبح
عليكم فالحين يمكن يقدم لكم مختن طبعا
يسعدك ويسعد ايامك ان شاء الله يفوز
المنتخب اللي تتمنينه يلا ههه
اليوم
مختلف في مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
طبعا مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي صراحه
ليس فقط المطار هنا ولكن
كافه اليوم تدعم قطر
النجاح واتمام نجاح بطولات نهائيات كاس
العالم طبعا مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجانب
المطارات الاخرى في السعوديه استعدت من
اجل استقبال او ايضا مغادره المسافرين الى
الدوحه لكن قبل ما يتغادر او قبل ما يغادر
المسافرين لازم يطولهم شويه من الفعاليات
والفرحه والبهجه وايضا الاحتفاليه مثل
ايضا عمليه التصميم لدخول المسافرين طبعا
احنا في موجودين في داخل صاله الحجاج في
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي وكذلك عمليه
الاستقبال وبعض الفعاليات لكن قبل ما
نتجول في كاميره العربيه راح اول راح
نتعرف انه كيف يتم استقبال هؤلاء مسافرين
وكيف مجادراتهم وكيف التجهيزات اللي
استعدت لها مطار الملك عبد العزيز خاصه في
جوف عاليات جميل جدا معانا يعني واحده من
الموظفات في وزاره الرياضه واللي استعدوا
هنا في مطار الملك عبد العزيز اول شيء
نتعرف عليك
اهلا وسهلا فيك طيب
استعلامات الجمهور ونشوف فعاليات ونشوف
ملعب كره قدم والبوصات حتى باللون الاخضر
[موسيقى]
احنا نساعده شكرا لك يعطيك الف عافيه
وبرضو من الفعاليات اللي هو موجوده كما
نشاهد الان عمليه يعني وضع الارضيه بشكل
بساط وهناك بعض المطاعم طبعا اليوم نتكلم
من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي قام بوضع
اكثر من عدد من الحافلات التردديه اللي
تنقل السياح من مطار صاله ورقم واحد
الصاله الاخرى الى هذه الصاله واصاله
المغادره وبرضه قام بتجهيز استراحات همم
يعني تستوعبني اكثر من همم
150,000 مسافر طبعا اليوم الرحلات
تغادر فقط من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الى
الدوحه اكثر من مثل من 800 رحله ويتوقع
انه عدد المسافرين يصلون الى
250,000 مسافر اضافه الى ايضا المسافرين
اللي راح يجون ترانزيت من اوروبا وامريكا
الى جده
كمرحله ترانزيت قبل وصولهم الى وجهتهم
النهائيه الى الدوحه طبعا في الجهه الاخرى
انا لو امشي يمكن بوصل الدوحه من كثر ما
نمشي من كثر الفاعليهات الموجوده هنا في
الجهه الاخرى ايضا في شاشه كبيره جدا
وكراسي او مقاعد وضعت من اجل لحظه استراحه
او وصول المسافرين او المغادرين من هذه او
من هذا المطار قبل توجههم الى الدوحه
لمشاهده بعض المباريات وكذلك من مشاهده
البرامج الرياضيه اضافه الى وضع او زوايا
وكذلك اماكن مخصصه لشرب القهوه وكذلك
الماكولات الخفيفه هذه الشاشه الكبيره
اللي تشعر كانك حاضره كاس العالم وكانك
موجود في قلب الدوحه انا صراحه علي يعني
انا باخذها رايح جاي ابي شاهد مباراه هنا
ومباراه في الدوحه وهذه يعني
وبادره جيده
لقينا الرياضيين بالمباريات اسم الله عليك
على هالصبح وبانتظار مباراه الارجنتين
السعوديه
والارجنتين الساعه 12 بتوقيت مكه شكرا
من مطار الملك عبد العزيز في جده مراسل
صباح العربيه